Nếu có cảnh có chính di quân sự của Mỹ và esprown nhớ người yên ràng tiếp tục lao thang,
tổng đồng cuối tế đang chừng vận về tính hợp phá của những hành động này theo lượng phá cuối tế.
Còn thứ kê lên của vãn Trung Nho cơ trời res cảnh báo rằng chua tấn công và trả đuối cuối tế đến soạn
nhiên chạm tới hòa bình bạn đến cuối tế đồng thời nhấn mạnh,
biến trưng lên của cống sự dùng của lực chống lại cho anh về lãnh thầu.
Hãy độc lập trị của bất kỳ sau nào.
Các quân nhìn quế đến độc cuối của ông,
và nhóm trưa ra được lập kêu hòa, chấm rất cảnh động của sự,
tế này nếu chơi độc lập về cá mục vi phạm lực tiến đạo,
có chuyến giản những mạnh cái chính xe quân sự phải tôn thuộc quyền tắc phân biệt một tiêu của sự và giân sự.
Bởi vì giảm tính tương sướng và chẳng tụi vàong không cần thiết.
Các bầu viện như tấn công, chừng học tại miếng ác i vàng,
khiến hơn một chăm sóng mươi trẻ thiệt mạc.
Đã khi như tổ chức của tế thông dột cơ trẻ nếu chơi độc lập,
hệ thông này sẽ thu tập bằng chính từ vệ tên và đà hồ dưới tế và hiện trường.
Để chuyển tới các quân tự pháp của tế nếu phát hiện viva.
Các lãnh đạo của tế như tổng thống thu nhỉ kiếm RENSEF Tế YF Edogeàn và Hồng E. P. Chó,
Pha Rho Lêng từ vật thích căn,
cạnh báo việc miệng mình chức khu tấn công dưới sành nghĩa từ vệ phòng người.
Có thể làm suy yếu lập pháp của tế,
dù có cuối điều trai không luôn giãn tới phía nguạn ngay lập tất,
chúng vẫn là tất sở quân trọng, nể sắc lập sự thật và tạo án lực chính trị đối với các bên tham chiến.
Đồng thời của ngà với tự đối với thuàn bộ hệ thống lập pháp của tế hiện tại.